good morning John give me four minutes
so that we can have a legit conversation
about a warmer earth and what that means
for actual weather the kind of
conversation that we never get to have
because it doesn't fit into a 15-second
soundbite here's what we all need to get
and I don't think it's anybody's fault
for not getting this we talked about the
effect that a warmer earth will have on
the weather we're not talking about
what's gonna happen we're talking about
what's probably gonna happen or more
properly the probability of what will
happen we are never gonna know how many
big storms are gonna hit the US and any
given hurricane season but we can take a
look over the last 50 years and see how
many major storms formed per year and
I'm doing that right now I'm putting a
dot for every year most of the years had
two storms some of them had five some
non for some feds zero that year with
seven storms there that was 2005 the
year that Hurricane Katrina hit New
Orleans alright yeah you see what
happened here there is a curve this is a
probability distribution and it is
always how we should be thinking about
how a changing climate is affecting
weather today now this year not the dots
the curve every year at the end of the
hurricane season this probability curve
collapses into just another dot it is no
longer a set of things that could happen
it becomes a very specific thing that
did happen last year it collapsed into
four major storms the year before that -
the year before that - again in the year
before that zero oh do we have a you
have a trend happening here no no no
this is not a trend every year the curve
runs itself again and it might collapse
down to zero or it might collapse out to
seven like look at the dots obviously no
one dot on this curve is important and
also the curve is saying that all this
stuff happened everything that's in here
is well inside of the realm of normality
the number of serious storms from year
to year can jump dramatically well being
the effect of the same probability curve
a warmer planet doesn't take you from
this to this because global energy in
the system isn't the only important
variable it takes you from this to this
something important is changing and
that's shifting the curve with that new
curve collapses into its reality dot
that might still be at zero it's just
less likely than it used to be and
here's like 2005 will still be rare they
will just be less rare
and if there are more strong storms
there's a higher likelihood that they'll
end up hitting in the worst places
possible as Harvey did as Katrina did
homes that used to be considered safe
might now find it difficult to get
insurance because no one understands
probability curves like the people who
work at insurance companies and these
probability curves are what we use to
determine whether a flood has like a 1
in 100 chance of happening or a 1 in 50
chance of happening and as that changes
those hundred-year floods start to not
be hundred-year floods and the curve can
shift before we're aware of it like with
this we only get one new dot a year
which is why we create computer models
so that we can run hurricane seasons
over and over and over again with
slightly changed variables to see what
will happen and what we see with more
energy in the global system is the
curves shifting towards stronger wetter
storms the more carbon we release of the
atmosphere the more these curves shift
and that is the future that we have to
accept and the one that we have to
prepare for and also the one that it's
good to try and understand a little bit
so thanks for taking four minutes to do
that John I'll see you on Tuesday
that took substantially less than four
minutes I'm quite proud of myself so
here we are together in the inn's gonna
have so much time I'm going to Australia
see ya VidCon Australia Australia people
this shirt is the new giraffe love shirt
designed by Ming Doyle I like it a lot
you can get a D of T be a comm what else
should I talk about so let a backpack so
this is mine you can't have these are my
favourite fidget toys because they're
quiet
they make no noise I can play with a mom
on a phone call and it is not as noisy
as this everybody hated me and now they
don't anymore B there's a YouTube video
I should make you go watch crash Bros
film production with Lilly Gladstone so
good and the recent series on guns in
America from healthcare triage really
well done okay bye